für ihre stirn können wir botox
verwenden ist dass das was sie mit mir
machen wollten
sieht ganz schön brutal aus seid ihr
zufrieden mit ihrem aussehen
in italien muss viele leute
offensichtlich nicht denn italien ist
europas nummer eins in sachen
schönheitseingriffe gleichzeitig kosten
immer mehr junge menschen vor allem
frauen ganz offen über ihre apps
umstrittene lux wie fox eis trend in den
sozialen medien und durch corona steigen
die zahlen noch mehr
sie fragen nicht nach schmerzen sie
fragen nicht nach komplikationen
sie wollen nur das ergebnis sehen ich
will wissen ist operiert das neue normal
in italien
und welche rolle spielen soziale medien
mein name ist marie reiche ich bin
journalist und komme aus wie für diesen
film habe ich mich auf den weg nach
italien gemacht
ins zentrum der schönheit nach rom was
mich interessiert ist die meinung der
jungen leute hier in rom und wie sehr
dieser ganze schönheitswahn und das
ganze thema schöner zug ist wirklich ein
ding für sie ist
[Musik]
wieso ist schönheit so wichtig in
italien
ich glaube das teil ist sehr wichtig in
italien ich denke auch wegen social
networks es ist so wichtig weil wir sehr
stark von social media beeinflusst sind
wir sehen ständig wunderschöne leute
immer perfekt das ist ein regelrechter
standard ist social media
tik tok instagram deine große
beeinflussen würdet ihr ein schöner zug
in betracht ziehen
ich persönlich nein ich auch nicht ich
würde gern eine stupsnase habe ich würde
gerne die nase neu machen
ja ich würde nase und lippen machen weil
die viel zu dünn sind
hast du schon gesagt ja nicht nur für
wirklich viele der frauen mit denen ich
gesprochen habe wer eine schöne zeit
durchaus denkbar
würdet ihr persönlich operieren lassen
schreibt es in die kommentare
ich treffe jetzt jemanden der mit dem
hype um schöner zug ist sein geld
verdient nämlich dr
er ist arzt in rom und sehr präsent auf
social media ich habe ein team in berlin
[Musik]
dr lighting und sein team operieren etwa
500 italienerinnen im jahr zirka 80
prozent davon sind frauen
auf instagram wirbt er für seine
eingriffe ein viertel seiner
patientinnen ist unter 25 jahren
[Musik]
gibt es ein mindestalter bei ihnen 18 18
ist ziemlich jung für plastische
chirurgie oder nicht
patientinnen die über 18 sind können das
selbst entscheiden
besonders bei brüsten und nasen haben
sie manchmal defekte die sehr sehr
wichtig für sie sind da ist es für die
entwicklung besser das zu korrigieren
auch wenn sie erst 18 sind es gibt eine
hohe nachfrage nach schönes eingriffen
in italien hat die in letzter zeit
zugenommen bei ihnen ja es ist
unglaublich
während des lok downs haben kosmetische
behandlungen und opis stark zugenommen
patientinnen konnten keinen urlaub
machen und deswegen hatten sie mehr geld
und wegen apps wie skype sehen sie ihr
gesicht mehr
und dann wollen sie ihre ganzen defekte
korrigieren die offiziellen zahlen
bestätigen dass alleine in 2009 10 sind
schönheitseingriffe in italien und ganze
27,5 prozent gestiegen das sind knapp
234 1500 kg und nicht chirurgischen
eingriffe mehr als im vorjahr
seit corona dürften die zahlen noch
deutlicher steigen denn die folgen einer
operation lassen sich im home office
oder unter der maske verstecken
eine junge patientin hat heute einen
termin bei dr francesca konter vor
eineinhalb jahren mit 22 ließe sich die
brüste vergrößern
vor sechs wochen hatte sich die lippen
mit hyaluronsäure aufspritzen lassen
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
fandest du deine brust zu klein und habe
auf jeden fall breite schultern und
meine brust war eindeutig zu klären
nicht proportioniert je älter ich werde
umso mehr spürte ich das bedürfnis
weiblicher zu sein
francesca schönheitsbild von
weiblichkeit ist geprägt von instagram
und co
sie selbst ist sehr aktiv auf social
media können sie den einfluss von social
media auf ihre arbeit sehen naja es ist
verrückt
instagram gehört zu unserem alltag das
ist auch ein problem denn manche leute
wollen als völlig anderer mensch
erscheinen als der der sie in der
realität sind kommen leute manchmal mit
bestimmten face filtern von instagram zu
ihnen oder bildern von social media und
sagen das ist genau das was ich ganz
genau deshalb verändern instagram und
facebook wirklich unsere gesellschaft
weil patientinnen zu uns kommen und
denken sie gehen zum friseur weißt du
sie fragen nicht nach schmerzen fragen
nicht nach komplikationen
sie wollen nur das ergebnis sehen
mein eindruck ist dass er den
schönheitswahn in italien sehr wohl auch
kritisch sieht aber der ist natürlich
auch teil dieser milliarden
ich habe zwar nicht vor mit unters
messer zu legen aber wenn ich schon mal
hier bin will ich zumindest wissen was
würden die beiden an mir fern
okay wir könnten da eine behandlung
machen das ist kosmetische medizin
da gibt es einiges biologen säure die
wir von hier in diesen kleinen kanal
indizieren
diesen part zu füllen für deine stirn
könnten wir brotbox nutzen sowie die
botox auch hier für diesen bereich an
orden kannst lächelt noch mal ja diese
falte wird also auch weggehen
ich mag diese falten
das würde mich das kosten zb meine augen
zu machen
normalerweise 400 euro und wie oft muss
ich das machen
ein oder zweimal im jahr du wolltest
offensichtlich was an meiner nase
verändern
was würdest du endlich könnte ich würde
die spitze ende speziellen haben
das müssen wir operieren das geht nicht
mit injektionen naja ich denke das ist
eben meine nigerianischen larsen mit der
lebe ich eigentlich gerne denkst du es
ist okay wenn auch männer opels machen
in diesem alter nein ich würde es tun
du denkst also ob es in den frauen
ganz ehrlich bis vor kurzem habe ich
noch nie ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht
irgendwas er mir verändern zu lassen
aber je mehr ich mich mit dem thema
auseinandersetzt desto mehr fallen mir
auch die kleinen makel an mir auf
über 85 der schönheitseingriffe weltweit
werden an frauen vorgenommen was sie
bereit sind dafür auf sich zu nehmen
sehe ich später noch bei doktor lazzari
dem op social media scheint ein treiber
fischer als ideale zu sein
soweit nichts ungewöhnliches aber was
macht italien dann zum spitzenreiter
warum verfängt sich diese idee
ausgerechnet hier so es gibt eine spur
zwei frauen bringen mich darauf
franziska geliebt und barbara bach
die beiden haben ein buch zum thema frau
seien in italien geschrieben
ich konstatiere für uns ganz klar vom
fernsehen ausgegangen dass es in der
gesellschaft heute für frauen einen sehr
starken druck gibt eigentlich immer sexy
sein zu müssen
es gibt nach wie vor drei bis vier
fernseher in vielen haushalten die
eigentlich oft unentwegt laufen als ist
eigentlich das häufigste
hintergrundgeräusch und dieses
hintergrundgeräusch dröhnt vor
stereotypen
denn in den 50er jahren verbreitet sich
in italien ein frauenbild im fernsehen
das sich bis heute kaum verändert hat
die frau als hübsches puppenhaft
überwiegend operiert halbnackt und sturm
symbolfiguren ohne tragende inhaltliche
funktion so zum beispiel weist retailer
notiz in der show damen in ihre rolle
nicht sprechen dürfen auch dann nicht
wenn sie angesprochen werden
diese show läuft sechs mal pro woche zur
primetime 4,5 millionen italiener innen
sehen sie im schnitt haben die sich mit
social media nationale gesetz es geht in
italien hand in hand also menschen weil
man auch frauen die im fernsehen gewöhnt
wurden sind es wiederum auf den sozialen
medien oder umgekehrt
aufgrund vieler voller kriegen sie dann
eine rolle im fernsehen als
co-moderatorin oder tänzerin
mir wird klar das fernsehen hat das bild
der frau in italien geprägt und tut es
immer noch und social media ist wie ein
brandbeschleuniger für diese stereotype
ich spreche mich unterschiedlichen
menschen darüber aber um dieses image
und die welt der schönen in italien gp
zu verstehen will ich jemanden treffen
der auf dieser welt kommt ich treffe
mich jetzt mit einer frau die das
italienische schönheitsbild geradezu
perfekt verkörpert sie heißt rené ist in
pflanzen sängerin und die tochter einer
bekannten tv moderatorin du bist damit
aufgewachsen deine mutter ist eine
bekannte tv show präsentieren
sie ist sehr prominent in den
italienischen medien ist das schon sehr
jung erlebt wie empfindest du die
italienische unterhaltungsbranche
meine mama hat mir immer erzählt wie das
war als sie jung war als sie den beruf
angefangen hat wie schwer das war und
dass es sich in der tat um einen job
handelt der voller auf opfere west weil
die eigentliche wahrheit ist die hinter
den kursen
das hat mich immer fasziniert sie selber
ist sehr glücklich über die arbeit die
sie gemacht hat
sie hätte es vielleicht sogar lieber
noch länger gemacht aber dann hat sie
andere entscheidungen getroffen
sie hat den fehler gemacht zu heiraten
ist es zu viel druck und ist es mehr
geworden durch social media
ja in der tat gibt es viel druck und
auch zum teil aufgrund von social media
aber nicht nur denn die in gänsefüßchen
falsche schönheitsideale und den druck
den haben sie zum beispiel schon in der
schule also mit sicherheit wird ein
falsches niveau an schönheit angestrebt
also nach dem was ich gehört habe bist
du ja auch selbst operieren
wie kam es dazu und wie ist deine
persönliche meinung also erstmal weiß
ich nicht wer das erzählt aber ich habe
keine hobbys gemacht
an sich bin ich aber nicht dagegen ganz
im gegenteil ich denke wenn es ein
menschen helfen kann sich besser mit
sich selbst zu fühlen dann ist es gut
ich habe freundinnen die das gemacht
haben menschen die ich kenne und ich
sehe auch nicht wo das problem ist offen
darüber zu sprechen weil ich sowieso
glaube dass 90 prozent der leute die ich
kenne das machen rené startet gerade mit
ihrer ersten eigenen offiziellen single
durch sie hat viele termine
aber sie verspricht mich später noch ein
bisschen mitzunehmen in ihre welt und
sie bringen doch eine überraschung mit
sagt sie es gibt in italien auch
gegenbewegungen frauen die das
schönheitsideal umkrempeln wollte ich
lerne eine von ihnen kennen
elisabetta kapital
sie ist eine koryphäe des italienischen
feminismus kandidiert gerade als
bürgermeisterin von rom und ist mitglied
einer der größten feministischen
bewegung in italiens casa internationale
delle donne diese fotos da sind wir ja
ganz junge mädchen
es sind bilder beweise unserer kämpfe
zum beispiel für die abtreibung für die
scheidung weil die katholiken dieser
gesetze abschaffen wollten nicht nur
frauen die eltern wollen sich operieren
lassen sondern auch tine warum frauen im
allgemeinen werden immer beurteilt
anhand ihrer sexuellen anziehungskraft
das ist derselbe grund warum berlusconi
behauptet hat dass angela merkel eine
unwägbare dickbäuchige sei sie bringt
kein man in versuchung kein man würde
mit ihr sex haben also das bedeutet im
umkehrschluss dass wenn ihr eine frau
sieht er sich fragt will ich mit der sex
haben die antwort nein ist dann ist
diese frau nichts wert dieser druck
entlädt sich auch auf die jungen mädchen
also wenn sie schönheitschirurgie in
anspruch nehmen dann lässt sie das mit
der welt im einklang sein
lisa will mit den feministinnen des
verbands eine neue kampagne auf den weg
bringen an italienischen schulen wollen
sie mit jugendlichen über
schönheitsideale und opis sprechen
um den zusammenhang besser zu verstehen
und um vielleicht ein alternativ bild zu
schaffen
was glaubt ihr kann so eine aktion an
schulen wirklich helfen
schreibt eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare während meiner zeit in rom
gibt eine ziemlich bizarre story in den
sozialen netzwerken wieder only london
eigentlich weißer brite hat sich 18
schönert opels unterzogen um so
auszusehen wie die mit der das
südkoreanische sänger von bts
[Musik]
welchen preis sind menschen bereit für
ihr aussehen zu zahlen um das zu
verstehen muss sich in den op
deswegen war ich noch mal zu dr lassen
sie wird unser vorzeige modell sein für
operationen
hier haben wir alles die reanimation der
patientinnen hierfür das herz wenn etwas
schief geht
ich habe keine ahnung wofür das ist das
ist für faceliftings wenn man unter die
haut und anheben ja ganz genau dass es
zum nähen
das ist eine schere damit greift man die
haut bei einer op selbst glaube ich
wegen corona leider nicht dabei sein
aber doch gelassen zeigt mir original
material das er bei ubs aufgenommen hat
das sollte interessant werden
jetzt zeige ich dir wie man
brustimplantate einsetzt
[Musik]
das ist auch chirurgie ich öffne die
haut du siehst die muskeln sind komplett
ab
das ist unter lidstraffung das dass das
was sie mit mir machen wollten
das ist chirurgie das dient dazu den
fettsack unter dem auge zu entfernen
nein sie da wirklich ein siehst du das
das gelbe hier
das ist wirklich hart anzuschauen
die augen sind einfach so empfindlich
sind ich habe mehr als genug gesehen und
dr city hat jetzt feierabend
und ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich bin auch
gar nicht böse dass ich nicht live bei
einer op mit dabei sein konnte okay man
besuch in der klinik war sehr intensiv
teilweise echt fast überfordert gerade
der teil im op hat mir bewusst gemacht
so eine operation ist wirklich nicht
einfach ein haarschnitt oder sowas
nach all dem kann ich einen drink it die
influenza in rene hat mich eingeladen in
einer beliebten bar mit ihnen rom ihren
freund und zwei freundinnen zu treffen
dass ich nicht wusste ist dass ein vip
tisch sitzen
was machst du beruflich ich spiele
fußball auch beruflich das tool ist
ungefähr 45 jahren wo spielst du ihr
würdet ihr ein schöner zug in betracht
ziehen
habt ihr schon welche gedacht ich nicht
ja ich habe vor etwas an der nase machen
zu lassen
da bin ich ganz ehrlich ich bin ganz
ehrlich um die brust oder klima schärfe
ich habe bis jetzt nur darüber
nachgedacht nicht die heads auf keinen
fall aber wer weiß irgendwann vielleicht
nach einem kind jetzt sind sie ja straff
auch wenn sie nicht super groß sind ist
es okay
und wie siehst du das bei männern gleich
wieder das ist doch ein bisschen anders
männer lassen sich tendenziell nicht
operieren auch wenn man eine größere
nasa hat männer haben an sich eventuell
züge die etwas gröber sind ich zum
beispiel habe eine ziemlich fette nase
aber ich habe nicht hinterfragt ob ich
mir die nase machen lassen soll
andere körperteile also ein mann der
sich operieren lässt den verstehe ich
weniger in akzeptiere ich auch weniger
kein thema jeder ist frei das zu tun was
man möchte nichts falsch
genau zum teil machen diese kleinen
macken einen mann aus rené für das leben
nach dem sich viele mädchen in italien
sehne influenza in sängerin erfolgreich
schön und fußballerfrau
rené reproduziert bewusst oder unbewusst
das rollenklischee der frau für das
italien so bekannt ist unser kameramann
ein italiener bringt es nach dem treffen
auf den punkt man oder besser gesagt
frau kein in italien alles erreichen
wenn sie schön ist
[Musik]
nicht interessiert eure meinung
verlernen wir durch den permanenten
vergleich auf social media objektiv über
und so aussehen zu urteilen oder sind
instagram und ticket vielleicht sogar
mittel zu mehr im power nennt schreibt
es in die kommentare und damit bis zum
nächsten mal
bei trending
[Musik]